سواء امن البعض بالتعليم عن بعد او رفضه
كان على الجميع الانحناء امام هذا الخيار
مع اجتياح جائحه كورونا للعالم وقبوله لكن
ذلك لم يكن ايذانا ببدء هذه التقنيه التي
جاءت كنتاج لجهود مكثفه خلال اكثر من
ثلاثه قرون فكيف حدث ذلك في عام
1728 نشر رجل يدعى كلب فيليبس اعلانا في
صحيفه بوستنغازت لدوره تدريبيه بالمراسله
عن طريق تبادل رسائل البريد استمرت
الدورات بالمراسله في الانتشار لاحقا لكن
اول شكل رسمي لها كان في عام
1858 عندما اصبحت جامعه لندن رائده في
تقديم شهادات التعلم عن بعد واتاحت فرصه
التعلم للطلاب من خلفيات اقل ثراء فسميت
حينها جامعه الشعب كذلك ظهرت ناجحه اخرى
حول العالم ففي المانيا قام الفرنسي
تشارلز توسان بانشاء مدرسه للغه بالمراسله
في عام
1856 فيما نجحت في تصميم برنامج تشجيع
الدراسات باستراليا في عام
1873 كذلك قدمت كليه كولير الامريكيه
برامج متخصصه لعمال المناجم الراغبين في
تطوير قدراتهم في عام
1890 في النصف الاول من القرن العشرين
اتاحت الجامعات حول العالم دورات
بالمراسله بغرض الوصول للطلاب الريفيين في
عام
1922 كانت كليه ولايه بنسلفانيا اول كليه
تبث دورات عبر شبكات الراديو لتفتح الباب
لان تصبح اكثر من عشره بالمئه من محطات
البث الاذاعي مملوكه للمؤسسات التعليميه
في التالي بحلول عام
1934 بدات جامعه اياوا في بث اول دورات
متلفزه قبل ان تحذوا كليات اخرى حذوها الى
ان نجحت جامعه جنوب افريقيا في ان تكون
اول جامعه عامه في العالم تعتمد التعليم
عن بعد في عام
بعد ذلك بوقت قصير ومع ظهور شبكه الويب
العالميه افتتحت جامعه جونز الدوليه برامج
التعليم العالي المستند على الانترنت
بالكامل مع بدايه الالفيه الثانيه قدمت
العديد من المؤسسات التعليميه الخاصه
والعامه فرصا للتعليم عن بعد كما ظهر
المعلمون والمدربون بالمجالات المختلفه
عبر المنصات الالكترونيه التي اتيحت غالبا
بالمجاني للعامه
في عام 2020 اجبرت جائحه كوفي 19 المؤسسات
التعليميه حول العالم على استخدام ميزات
التعلم عن بعد لكن هذا البديل الذي قد يرى
فيه البعض المستقبل لا يزال يفتقد للقبول
الفعلي على ارض الواقع